you're listening to inside of you you
forget with Michael Russell's bomb I
think that was the first time I just
kind of go wait a minute what he has one
of those mornings I just did some yoga
bra and I walked in on your yoga sesh I
know I wanted you to meet my yoga
instructor in case you needed a yoga
person because you had all the surgery
so it's good though yeah
stretch it out bro it is yeah yeah it's
very important to stretch it you don't
to worry about that you're a very
healthy non surgery kind of guy I should
probably stretch more I mean I'm tall I
got a lot of limbs you do your degree
I'm six no six zero are you six zero
zero that's like Taj two point what is
it
Tosh to tosh point-o tosh point-o is it
tosh point-o tosh point-o yeah and
you're ryan 6.0 ryan 6.0 got it yeah you
know last week just to talk briefly
about that because it certainly was
probably the biggest response of any
podcast episode I've had and that was
Stephen Amell kudos to Stephen for for
being brave as I've said I did a KTLA
interview it was just viral I think we
were number two on Yahoo it was nuts man
it was like you know and thanks thanks
to Stephen for bit again being brave man
it's just like you know a lot of people
especially celebrities they're always
like oh can you cut that I don't want to
sound like that and I've done that I did
just did that with Eric Griffin I was on
his podcast and you know did Jeff dies
podcast and you know I I thought shoot
man should I have said that and you know
you start questioning yourself but yeah
you're gonna say the wrong things but
like you know Stephen he said let me
hear the video let me hear the audio
they were all yelling he listened he
said yeah man because I thought it I
think it was important I think it's
important and I could just tell and
people were like good on you good on you
Stephen
I want to make this clear it's not like
you know this podcast is about this is
all about mental health this is all
about you know anxiety and this that's
not what the pocket the podcast really
is about being honest talking to people
and just being open and seeing how they
made it when they faced it
versity what they did you know and I and
of course I get an anxiety and
depression and all these things because
I experienced them so I always wonder if
someone else did and then maybe they
could help me and that they have any
insight I'm always looking for like
somebody's gonna have more information I
think that's what it's about like when
you talk to someone you might get
something from someone so you say oh I'm
gonna try that do you feel that way yeah
I was expecting me pointed at all right
clear my throat sorry yeah that's fine
expected to be what pointed that I just
point out yeah you did
did I yeah point you mean like like ask
asking you the question yeah you weren't
you thought I was just gonna keep
rambling and not directed towards you
that was I was I was ready to sort of
zone out
yeah well though I gotta I gotta be a
bit better about that thank you I didn't
know you're gonna talk to me well that
ain't not being present right only
person in the room that's about being
present but you know it's uh I think
when we talk to people and we you know
people listen to this we look I don't
want to listen to a podcast about mental
health and it's more about you know
sitting down with celebrities athletes
all these different influential people
by the way I'm gonna have other people
in the show like um therapist I'm trying
to get dr. drew you know those things
are fun but I'm just trying to improve
myself I think that's what it is like
how do I feel better how do I get better
you know what things can I try that
aren't you know certain things aren't
working for me so what can I do to make
things work better like for you you
don't do yoga you don't stretch you
don't do any of these things so maybe
you start doing something and it becomes
a routine and it helps you yeah that
should do these things
I just don't maybe cuz you're young how
old you 31 stood I could be your father
I am you know guy I am your father Ryan
what's it sophomore year at high school
Ryan taya's rosenbaum yeah that'd be
weird I don't think I had sperm then I
mean I did but it wasn't effective I
think those shooting blanks til probably
30 I don't know I was a late bloomer man
me too yeah yeah
I didn't start puberty too late if we
ever played skins and shirts and
basketball I sat out if I was a skin
like nah I just I think I twisted my
ankle just now what we didn't start
playing we just chose whose skins our
shirts
yeah I don't want to take my shirt off I
should probably have hair under my
armpit and I don't so I want to let
everybody know that I'm going to Mexico
I'm going to Richmond Virginia for cons
if you're interested if you're near the
area come see me we do a Smallville
Knights
Wehling and I that's it's fun you've
heard me say it I'm also in that patreon
now I think it's pretty fantastic I did
a live podcast
Instagram the other day I don't do a lot
of them so I'm on there and when I got
off there was like 30 people had joined
patreon in in like 20 minutes
it was insane dude it was last night
yeah I was like dude everybody was
really really cool and people are
subscribing to the podcast and I
appreciate it I really just am blown
away by it
also Tom Welling and I of course as you
know we knocking point wines Stephen
amell's company we've made our own line
again last year it's sold out it's
called pure evil is the name of our wine
it's two bottles of us looking at each
other I was the evil last year Tom was
the pure this year I'm the pure he's the
evil it's knocking point wines and it
sold out last year and they wanted to do
it again so we did it again and it's
almost sold out again so I don't know
it's a cool keepsake or whatever inside
of you is the code $10 off your first
box bringing the total of two $29 for
both bottles I think it's pretty fair
they're both great we did some wine
tastings I don't know a lot about wine
but I know what I like and it tasted
good Tom got something dark you know
richer you know manlier I'm always like
a little effeminate with my wines and
just my life it's knocking point wines
calm and we're called pure evil great
guests today and by the way Ryan we're
going video soon we are going video soon
in a few weeks we got a couple of weeks
left maybe what we're gonna say we're
trying to be strategic but we've done
some test stuff if you're on the patreon
you've already seen some we've got some
right I think we're posting some video
and what its gonna look like the show a
little test and we did a little
interview me you and Jeff yes yeah and
we did a little interview talking about
guests and things like that so you can
get extra but behind the scenes stuff on
the patreon I'm excited man this rooms
different it's we got cameras we we
spent a lot of money here trying to
make it look good and you know you could
still listen to it's gonna sound great
and it's going to look great and it's a
work in progress so get ready in the
next couple of weeks
right now she's been on the show before
I'm always pushing her too you know
she's always working so hard this girl
she's always working so hard I think
they're doing a spin-off she talks about
some stuff cuz you know she was Oliver
Queen's daughter on arrow but a dynamic
lady and I consider her a friend
although we don't hang out but I still
consider her friend is that weird no
that's about it let's get right in to
Katherine McNamara it's my part of you
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
captain Merrick I already messed it up
Katherine this there have been very few
guests that have come on more than once
Tom Welling mm-hmm Zac Levi Katherine
McNamara oh my goodness and maybe it's
cuz they don't want to come back I don't
really know the whole answer but you
know I some guests I want like jenna
fischer i go will you come Esther's I
will absolutely come back and I believed
her she wants to come back she had a lot
of fun I think she was surprised I think
she probably liked a podcast and but you
had fun last time much fun it was my
first podcast ever and I'm I'm a huge
podcast nerd so I am a listener of your
podcast and you do listen to me do
what's your favorite episode oh well
it's funny because I listen to Stephens
episode before I hit a man yes Stephen
amell's episode before I had met him
because I knew I was going on the show
your episodes exactly why are always
awesome cuz that's a good friend of mine
as well he's the best so you listen to
Stephen amell's episode is that because
you wanted at that time that's on your a
little sneaky I wouldn't say sneaky you
couldn't you withheld some information I
did but only because I was sworn to
secrecy by my employer which was era
which was arrow which was the CW or the
WB or what is it any other companies but
basically I when I first came on your
podcast I had just been cast in arrow
and if there's any podcast I would have
loved to talk about that on it would fit
this one yeah right but I couldn't I
couldn't even breathe a word of it now I
get confused I don't know it's not I
don't think Steve would be upset with
this but I've seen an episode of arrow I
watched him I go oh good he's good
that's it's a nice show but it's not
like I watch arrow I don't watch you
know people assume that you know cuz I
was Lex Luthor I must love comics I love
you know this I love people yeah and
also I go to a lot of conventions to
sign and I used to go to conventions to
watch you know to meet horror legends
because I'm a huge horror fan as I know
you're a big heart so we'll get into
that I know because we talked about it
briefly before but so I would
he actors at a convention so it was easy
for me to say hey I was like yeah you
were Superman like Brandon Ralph was
like yeah I'd love to do it man I was a
cool how the other Superman and maybe
I'll so it's easy to get gas people are
cool you get to know people being at
these conventions as you know you've
done a lot of conventions I've done a
lot of conventions they're the best I
love them do you make a ton of
money
I don't know comparatively I feel like
people like you and William Shatner and
make a lot more shatner that's not true
look I first of all I will say one thing
about the conventions a lot of people
don't know this many people think oh
yeah these up places and you take
people's money
some people will assume that and I
thought that for a long time and then I
actually realized wait a minute I am a
fan I used to come to these conventions
this is a vacation for me this it's like
almost if Katherine McNamara on her week
off of arrow was like I'm going to
Hawaii well these people these fans
these friends a lot of my listeners they
come see me at conventions or their
heroes why isn't that a great vacation
if you're gonna go meet people that you
admire or people you want to meet and
you cosplay and there's events and
there's I but look at all the toys I
have in my house this is this is because
of cons I love the Imperial Walker also
known as an ad at yes yeah I think
they're really cute right yeah I know
they are cute you want you would you
like that I wouldn't take it it's so
perfect up here but I appreciate it for
sure well I'll try to find you one okay
would you really put that your house I
actually might I have a little tiny it
pop doll I have a few little things
around me yes pop doll huh now why do
you have that is it because Isaiah
Mustafa your former co-star in
Shadowhunters was in it too I mean I was
a huge fan of it before Isaiah was a
part of it but partially because of
Isaiah and partially because I just I
love that story and that property in
that film but it was actually at a
convention that I got that it popped all
I was in New Zealand some fan gave it to
you you saw it no I
it was at the pop booth and I saw a
little one and I freaked out over it and
bought it who's a little clown like a
little clown keychain exactly if you
look at my backpack for work I have all
of these enamel pins on it and half of
them are it I've got like
little SS Georgie and a balloon that
says we all float it's it's a little
twisted but that's who I am
wasn't it cool by the way I'm not saying
that this is a friend of ours yeah
Isaiah Mustafa who was the Old Spice guy
and he was in a movie I cast him as play
one of my friends growing up and back in
the day and the movie back in the day
and he went on the Shadowhunters my dad
plays he played your dad in Shanghai and
he has grown so much as an actor I love
just watching his journey and now he's
married a wonderful Lisa and I just want
to give a shout out to say regardless of
what anybody thinks of the movie if they
love it they hate it does it doesn't
matter if you look at his performance I
thought he would give a solid
performance and he should get work from
that because he is he takes good
direction and he and he and he works
hard he really does and I've learned so
much from watching him and that's that's
part of how I learned how to kind of do
the job on Shadowhunters is by talking
to Isaiah and and you know every month
or so we'd have coffee find time in our
schedule and have coffee and just
chitchat and catch up and did he tell
you about things he tell you it was a
long time ago so don't even think that I
was like she's really she's really
pretty
yep okay I just saying she's pretty she
seems really nice and kind she's very
good she's very nice
that's eyes and ooh my Isaiah great
she's great okay good talking to you but
I remember the dad I knew didn't he he
pulled the dad on yeah I'm her dad
uh-huh
I love Isaiah you know he basically is
my dad at this point between him and
Steven I'm completely covered now are
explained to like because we're gonna
get into some stuff I want to get into
last time I know we talked about you
know you work all the time and I said
give yourself a break I think I told you
probably done that yeah you never give
yourself a break and you think if you
stop working you'll just like completely
freak out I don't know about that for me
it's it's because I love work and that's
that's part of why I do so many of these
conventions on the weekend like when I
was shooting arrow there were so many
times where I'd fly back and forth to
Korea for a day or two England
wait wait wait wait wait did you just
say flight to Korea for a day
you fly to Burbank for a day you fly to
San Fran maybe for a day you don't fly
to Korea for a day I did that's far
it's it's only a 10-hour flight from
Vancouver that's a lot you know but do
you work every day I was at that point
and you still muster up the energy and
the the attitude I slept for about 10
hours on the plane this is an
interesting guess guys because most the
time we talk about guests you know
people have their insecurities people
everybody hasn't scuse me people have
their anxieties and their depressions
and their things and the things that
make them tick and adversity they face
and you're talking I'm we're talking
today to someone who was on the show
before but maybe it's important to look
at someone who actually functions really
well under pressure and doesn't let the
best you know doesn't let things get to
her like we do the reason I fly back and
forth so much is because of these
conventions is because I I agree exactly
with what you were saying before it's I
had a long conversation with one of my
friends before I did my first convention
because I wasn't a hundred percent sure
about the whole concept of it and and
all of that it was a little strange they
didn't fully understand it but it's
become one of my favorite things because
you can connect with people and you we
pour our blood sweat and tears into
things as actors and a half the time
people just go it's like my dad my dad
will say I know dad I'm doing this movie
when's it gonna be in theaters well it's
an independent movie so it's not a real
movie no it could become a big manat
filming a real movie where no I'm in
it's like it's just in most movies they
just don't do what we hope they do most
shows fall under the radar I did a show
for two years called and pastor people
loved it not enough people of the rain
and things go away mm-hmm and that's the
story of our lives if we get a job and
we're working and then we're not exactly
les where Catherine Mack well it's truly
for me it's been so special to get to
actually because I've been a part of
these shows that have such fierce
fandoms to go meet people and connect
with people and hear their stories and
just
and and see the people that I see online
in person because they've especially the
Shadowhunters fans they have taken this
this fandom and their their love for the
show and taking it far beyond being fans
of us or being fans of our characters or
the show and created this movement and
this wonderful space for people to feel
accepted and loved and able to be their
true selves no matter who or what they
are and I want to support that as much
as I possibly can have you ever had
someone come up and cry to you and then
you get emotional several times actually
give me a give me a good example that
one that resonates in your head that you
you couldn't believe the impact you had
in someone's life and in your response
tell us about I I have one in particular
it was a girl that I was having a coffee
with and she sat down and said you know
I just I wanted to thank you for this
character and the story that you've told
because I lost my mom last year and I've
had to kind of take care of my 16 year
old sister and this girl is 18 and my
character on Shadowhunters lost her mom
at a certain point during that season
right around the time she'd also lost
her mom and a half of the season was
about dealing with that loss and
overcoming it and you know Clary
actually found her specific powers
through that grief and in dealing with
that and this girl had somehow connected
with that story and that he's emotional
to you she was and we both you know shed
a little tear and had a little cry and
you know cried to you cried with her I
couldn't help it I mean it's when these
stories are so touching and so beautiful
it's it's amazing you have to take a
deep breath and you have to feel it yeah
it's important to feel it I don't know
if it's you know some people I
understand everybody has different
strategies or not strategies but sort of
in that defense mechanisms but sort of
give me the word for God's sakes Ryan to
something you know I think they have
their ways of dealing with things
no Ryan if we meet somebody and they
start crying maybe Ryan will go oh I'm
sorry to hear that and he won't break
down or he won't whatever but you know
maybe I might just sort of like lose my
a little bit and like feel with
them yeah not always what I'm saying
people are not saying you would do that
I'm just sitting down no but like if
someone cries in front of you and
they're saying Ryan you really been an
influence in my life and thank you so
much and they're crying I'll say you
have the wrong person
I'm sorry sorry this is not me but
surely it's it's the big things and the
small thing so it's little things like
that but then also you know this just
goes to show you the the heart that is
in this fandom we were at a convention
in shadow for Shadowhunters we were at a
convention in Brussels I think it was
either Brussels or Paris I forget but we
came on for the U at the end of a
convention you go on you're like hey
thanks so much for coming guys bye see
you later we all walked up on stage and
suddenly they turned the lights off all
the kids pulled out these giant
heart-shaped balloons and started
singing the theme song can you sing it
this room of like well it's every well
song people people know I'm not a girl
just give me a look yeah I can't it's
the this is the hunt it's that song but
everybody sings for our show but they
sang the whole song and all of us on
stage were crying by the end of it all
of you guys - I think a couple of us I
don't I just seen Isaiah cry I've seen
him cry on screen and beautifully did he
use fake tears I don't think so
have you ever used to fake tears I have
but that's after like a 10-hour day
that's happy being a 20 time exactly
oh my god that's that's the hardest man
when you have to cry and you just can't
feel it or how about I remember crying
in a scene I was just emotional I wanted
them to blow the vapor or whatever in my
eyes and I had eight pages of dialogue
after that my eyes were swollen like
golf balls from a stone no I looked like
I remember the episode I remember how
terrible I looked for like these things
like oh my god can you guys do anything
what do you want us to do yeah no CGI my
Marvel my it's so funny though
cuz sometimes there are days where
sometimes if you're doing it 20 times
you need that by the end of it but then
other days it you'll just connect with
something on another level so deeply
that you don't need it and somehow it
comes every time do you think you're um
do you worry about how you look on set
do you won't you want to look great or
you just trust people enough to be like
hey they got my back what can I do isn't
it it's sort of a waste of time I think
we've all been there as an actor
like and secure your this and you got a
hope that somebody's watching you from
behind the monitor and says Rosenbaum
looks like he's got a huge booger
under his nose can someone go do you
have to have faith you do and it really
depends on the character for me like
there are some characters where you're
supposed to look good and you need to
look good and that's the point of it but
there are other characters and certainly
in particular scenes where you're
covered in blood and you're crying and
you're sweaty and you're supposed to
look horrible right as well I think you
should and those are the points where I
actually would rather look bad you know
that's something that I give aro so much
credit for is that Mia the character I
play on there is she's a boxer she's a
street fighter she is a badass she she
is and she gets hit in the face just as
much as the men on the show do and it
should show that so every time she gets
in a fight she comes out looking like
she's been beat the hell out of right
and as well she should but some shows me
a smoke you smoke me a queen by the way
do you feel like this is a woman
question it doesn't sound like it's
gonna be a good question I'll give you a
woman answer if you like well I might
just it's like this is only you can
articulate how you feel or in this room
particularly a mystery well that's pro
present company well like you're on
Shadowhunters you're on arrow you're
doing these movies do you ever feel like
especially in a very I mean you're the
lead in Shadowhunters mm-hmm
and you're doing all these scenes and
it's exhausting was there ever a time
where they because you're so kind
what can I say would you do the podcast
can you like yeah but I was like I
wonder if she really wants to do the
podcast do you ever feel compelled like
you just say yes to everybody and you
also say when they go hey we need you
tomorrow morning could you wave your
turnaround because it will save the crew
money and can you do this and all of a
sudden you're realizing you know they're
not asking the guys this do you ever
feel like I'm not saying show in
particular but have you ever felt like
anything they're taking advantage of the
fact that maybe I'm a woman or have you
ever felt like that I've never felt like
that in particularly and I think it's
because I have a perspective on it you
know if you can sort of tell which
productions are
a team and I've been very fortunate to
be a part of a lot of those productions
that work as a team and everybody
pitches in and everybody makes little
sacrifices to make the show because
ultimately it's all about working
together and everybody contributes that
little piece I am NOT above or a more
important piece than anyone else on that
set and that's kind of what I love about
chance you go home and go on the lead no
it's really hot honestly how I feel
about it because our industry is one of
those few left that you really can't do
it on your own you need a team around
you in order to make it the best it can
be and everybody is an expert in their
own field and can bring so much to that
and so much passion to that and when you
get a team of people that each person is
is so amazing at what they do it just
makes the whole so much greater than the
sum of its parts let me ask you
something about working on arrow in this
arrow universe and I'm not sure I
understand it I don't say that because I
don't like it I say it because I don't
understand it when there would they talk
of infinite earth yes and there's like
part one there's part right there's all
these parts yeah so let me let me am i
right am i around the right so there's
the show the flash there's the you know
there's Supergirl what else is there
Supergirl legends of tomorrow legends of
tomorrow
lightning Black Lightning right that
woman that way these are all on now yeah
so all these shows it's a crossover oh
yeah so when they say Infinite Earths it
means all these shows are compelling
yeah like you'll get a character from it
so it sounds very difficult it's very
difficult to keep track of and I think
the hero the real heroes of that are the
writers and the 80s because the writers
had to somehow coordinate their entire
seasons to build up five different shows
around this week of television basically
when you put it's a week one week so
it's split up there's half of it now and
then half of it after the holiday so how
many episodes total five five episodes
of crossover so if you do how many
episodes of arrow do you do a year well
this past season I did ten because it's
ten it's yes so it's over it's yes so
Stephen Amell comes over my house for
some reason he would be talking about a
show that he was on mm-hmm it's done
yeah
so you're acting with people from other
shows and I know they do that with
movies now with all those Marvel movies
exactly so that's where they kind of got
the idea it wasn't like an original idea
but it was a fault right it's kind of
the the Avengers endgame of the CW DC TV
universe as if you will but what's cool
about that is you not only have
characters from all of the CW shows
there's other characters from from other
parallel Earth's as well and that's kind
of how they work out well that's kind of
how they work out how Superman exactly
right yeah Brandon Ralph you have Tyler
hoechlin and you have Tom Welling who
all play Super Mario from different
about the Lex Luthor's they only had one
who's that oh they're Jon Cryer I know
they had Jon he was on the podcast were
you disappointed that I wasn't on the
show I would have loved to have you yeah
of course I loved all those people I
work with Welling either so there you go
yeah I don't know I think he worked with
Erica right and Jon I believe he worked
with Cryer maybe uh yeah he works Cryer
he also worked with hoechlin and Ekans a
nice guy too
yeah super super cool guy and you're
surrounded by a lot of guys yeah they're
there do you feel like there's a lot of
women and enough women I do shows
actually you know what that's it it felt
very balanced on the crossover because I
had several scenes with Melissa and Ruby
and with Katie and all these amazing
folks who it was in then equally with
like Grant and and Matt Ryan who plays
Constantine like Ryan I'm Alice right
else Wow because he's like I can't do it
watch text mental health and like
meditation usually listen this guy Alan
Watts how and what I'm doing Australian
aren't I
are there enough Jews on these shows I'm
Jewish there enough juice you know I
didn't ask
I didn't ask around to get everyone do
you do you get excited about work every
day you know because I know memorizing
lines so easy for you we talked about
that last time I think you can just look
at it and know it pretty much right when
I'm in the groove it I can read a scene
once or twice and know it why is that is
there is there certain like fearless
thing with you like you're just you have
so much confidence
that you don't even get nervous at all
that you can relax your mind can relax
and you can memorize this I think
it's just the fact that I was a huge
nerd growing up yeah because you're a
reader yeah you read a lot constantly
with a book in my hand constantly I
would memorize the infomercials by
accident as a kid like the phone numbers
if there was something that you know I
wanted as a Christmas present I just
write down the phone number I know one
which one 582 three hundred there you go
free app you should get them as an
advertiser yeah they do I think they
might need them no but the other cool
thing that's about the whole Infinite
Earths thing is we bring in characters
from other shows as well like we had Tom
Ellis from Lucifer come in and play you
know the devil himself from Earth 666
Conroy yeah it was kind of amazing to
see all these little cameos and these
characters brought in and also to see
the relationships between characters you
otherwise wouldn't see I thought it was
really cool for me uppity Q larly
because so many of these characters are
so close with all of our like caity lotz
is character and like grants Care Grant
Gustin who plays the flash those two
characters know Oliver so well and I had
a lot of work with them so they know
those qualities and can recognize those
qualities in Mia and then suddenly
they're either working with her butting
heads with her or managing her more
aggressive tendencies who do you love
working with but like I know you're
gonna say everyone because you're such a
nice person first for a second let's not
be as nice tell me who like when you
hear you're working with them today you
know it's gonna be the easiest day ever
you know that it's gonna be fun you know
it's not gonna be a pain in the ass I'm
not saying you don't love people equally
as much I'm saying who is that one
person that you just really get excited
to work with does it have to be just one
I'm really bad god no it - I'm not
saying you're your favorite I'm saying
like for instance Rob my friend Rob's
coming over yeah I know I'm a loser it's
Friday night yeah you know my friend Rob
is coming over Rob or Tom comes over
when lion comes over Ryan right here the
engineer when he comes over I get
excited like I like Ryan I like seeing
Ryan yeah he's easy to be around who
would you say well you know what I would
say I had a lot of fun working with
Stephen this year because I didn't get
to work with him last season at all yeah
the way the storylines were and now that
you know think thanks to crisis on
Infinite Earths the monitor brought me
in 20 years in the past and I had most
of my work with Stephen this season and
it was really so much fun why was it fun
he's just such an impeccable actor and
and I don't know there was something
about the way they wrote our scenes that
it was it put both of our characters off
of their studies your father exactly
where our characters we were each
other's biggest biggest vulnerability
and so being put right in front of your
biggest obstacle of your entire life and
having to deal with that also knowing
the world is ending and all these other
things they're happening it's it
instantly puts such confident characters
out of their comfort zone and as an
actor that's always fun to try and
figure out how biggest Stephen amell's
trailer he has actually one of the best
trailers I've ever seen why is that he
has an old Airstream it's awesome silver
well it's a new Airstream but it's lines
with him it'll read lines in the
Airstream no not in the perverted way I
don't think of it I got actually you
thought I was set thinking that and I
actually wasn't surprisingly okay good
yeah I wasn't going there and you are
I'm sorry but if you ask a woman if you
go hey did you go in his trailer that
sounds weird this day and age yeah any
damage inside of you is brought to you
by Sun basket I love me some Sun basket
I'm telling you it when they say Ryan
you are what you eat
it's not just a joke man yeah no one's
laughing after 2:00 a.m. and you're you
know after you've eaten your convenience
store burrito man selling like Matthew
McConaughey yeah hey man look man no one
wants it no one wants me laughing after
they ate a convenience store berate all
right all right all right it's true look
what I love about this some basket is
they have such a variety and that's what
I like to have a lot of options
especially because I'm trying to eat
healthy and I can make this stuff
because they give things that are
pre-portioned and ready to prep and cook
okay that's what I need because if you
asked me to go to the grocery store and
buy a bunch of stuff things gonna get
out of hand son basket caters to your
you're kind of healthy which I really
like delicious recipes for all kinds of
dietary preferences paleo gluten-free
Mediterranean vegetarian and more they
offer at least 14 recipes to choose from
you can try mouth-watering dishes I had
the salmon burgers with lemon dill mayo
come on man
ginger steak stir-fry with broccoli and
Mediterranean garlic shrimp and Spanish
rice with Spanish rice I can't eat that
because I'm allergic to shrimp but you
can Ryan oh great if you can right now
son basket is offering $35 off your
order when you go right now to son
basket calm slash inside and enter promo
code inside at checkout that son basket
calm slash inside enter promo code
inside at checkout for $35 off your
order
son basket calm / inside and enter promo
code inside inside of you is brought to
you by squarespace you want to start the
new year with a new website Squarespace
ready to start your new business make it
stand out get started with Squarespace
you think it dream it make it with
Squarespace a great thing here it's easy
to turn your cool idea if you have one
into a new website showcase your work I
don't know how many times you have this
idea yeah yeah we should do that yeah
and then you effing don't do that but
now you can do it you can make your
dreams a reality
sell products and services of all kinds
blog published content promote your
physical or online business announce an
upcoming event or special project and
more it's so easy to do you know that
you know Squarespace I do how do you
feel about it I feel good I mean I'm not
a I'm not a web designer and so it's
it's just like an easy yeah
you nailed it a guy like you doesn't
want to design a web site I don't know
tech now go I don't either
I'm here monitoring your computer not
knowing that's right
check out squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code I owe you
that stands for inside of you use the
offer code I owe you to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain at squarespace.com enter code I
you squarespace.com enter code IOU
I mean you're working so many actors and
it's got to be like do you ever is there
a time of your like kind of wish we'd be
done with this Infinite Earths think
it's exhausting I don't know what I'm
doing today I don't know it just seems
like it's so much like I would had a
panic attack every day there were days
of that but maybe it's just me and maybe
it's because I've been a part of so many
from Maze Runner to Shadowhunters to
this so many of these crazy we have so
many characters and everything's
happening all at once projects you just
resign yourself to the madness and lean
into the fun of it because you get to go
to work every day and wear a super suit
and work with some really cool people
and run around and you know I remember
looking around one day on set and I was
in my super suit and then there were a
couple Superman and Supergirl in the
flash and everybody and your green arrow
everybody was there and I'm just going
this is how is this my jobs how is this
what I get to do for a living you know
what you know you're you're one of those
people like my dad where I don't know if
this is true but I think my dad had more
fun when he went to work with his
colleague the boss guy and when he get
home he's kind of like I was gonna
he and I was like dad's home because he
just seemed happier when he was at work
I don't know maybe I'm wrong I'm just
saying it just felt that way in a lot of
ways whereas I think you love your work
that's what makes you happy yeah when
you go home for the holidays I mean you
see your mom and dad yeah go home and
see my grandparents my mom my friends
family there it's it's really as that
against Missouri Kansas City Kansas City
yeah I do you let go your work down I do
and that's why I go home for a couple
days cuz I my grandma's house has always
been my happy place they have a huge
woods in the backyard that I used to
just go wander around as a kid it was
like my literal and imaginative
playground and I used to just run around
in the woods by myself and make up fairy
tales as a kid and I think that's part
of why I became an actor I think I was
always a storyteller I just didn't know
that you could do that for a living and
eventually that's you know obviously I
did what I ended up doing is it hard
to be present with so much going on in
your life is it hard to be when you
listen when you're talking what--like
when we're talking right now
when people talk Christopher Walken once
said this he was on Conan O'Brien I'll
never forget I laughed so hard he goes
you know when people are talking they
they're thinking of other things what
I'm having a conversation with you I'm
thinking of a million things and Conan
says what are you thinking of and he
says I don't know tacos and so you know
like when you're with your family are
you thinking infinite crisis arrow this
Christmas movie I've got so much going
on are you really really do you can just
separate I can separate at this point
because there are so few times in my
life now that I do get to slow down and
by my own doing and by my own choice
because there's I I'm a workaholic I
like to be busy I like to do things that
I care about and I if if I can
physically make time for it why not but
when I'm home that's the time that I
actually do get to relax and just be
with my family because those those are
the rare things now those are the
special moments that I get to just catch
up and sit in my grandparents kitchen
and everybody wanders in and ends up
having you know second meal of leftovers
or we just open a pint of ice cream and
everybody grabs a spoon or you know look
at you differently though do you feel it
like there amongst or amidst someone of
amidst right Ryan you nod your head
amidst is the yeah yeah that's word yeah
it is but do you feel like sometimes
they treat you like you're someone
different no no they try not do right no
no and actually that's one of the things
that I love most about my family and my
friends from they don't care or they
pretend they don't care as far as I know
they don't see me any differently which
is I think wonderful I think the minute
they see me differently is the minute I
need to worry about what I am presenting
to the world there's no reason to be
anybody different because of what I do
or because of the jobs that I've done
that's true you know I'm still me but
you're very mature like you're you're
more mature
probably is 8 year old as I am now I
think I was more mature as an 8 year old
than I am now
yeah cuz you graduated high school when
you were 14 yeah yeah I mean there's no
can you me even a man I barely graduated
high school I think cuz I have a DD and
it was hard for me to focus but you
didn't have a DD no zoned in I was but
that's I also was allowed to do school
at my own pace and in a way that worked
for me so it it I think fostered exactly
what I needed educationally and I was
able to you know if I wanted to stand up
at my desk I could if I wanted to do my
homework outside in the middle of the
woods I could if I wanted to do it
standing on my head that was what I did
for the day or whatever I needed you
know and I could do math for 12 hours a
day if I wanted to or I could do you
know a little bit of everything as long
as I got it done by the time it was due
and that's that's what allowed me to let
my brain do what it needed and I just
kind of went at my own pace and suddenly
I was graduated before I even realized
it I was graduated I wouldn't even said
that right that right way I would've
said suddenly I graduated well that's
probably the proper no it's not I bet
it's not someone out there was going on
no she's right it's William Shatner yeah
she is what do you what scares you uh
missed opportunities stagnant stagnant
mm-hmm I think stagnant is equivalent is
death if you ever get married do you
ever think you'd ever wanna get married
I'd love to
you would I would yeah well did you hear
that Ryan she wants to get married every
time yeah I'd love that now what would
you look for in a partner somebody who
makes me better somebody who I can talk
to and debate with and who makes me
think and he makes me think differently
than I otherwise would you left out a
big one mm-hmm laughs well that's the
other part so he makes me laugh somebody
yeah of course I'm a big I'm a huge
goofball
you've that's how my whole family is
that way we'll laugh about a situation
before anything else I don't my
grandparents for example I don't think
I've ever seen them fight once in my
life they'll make a situation silly and
about it hold it before anything else
they're in their 70s does your
grandmother ever take you aside and just
tell you how much she loves you yeah I
was proud of you she is she texted me
yesterday she's like I love your pink
hair is your hair pink yeah do you know
I'm colorblind I just thought it was
like a white no it's pink yeah I am
colorblind so I can't differentiate a
lot of colors I can see colors but I
can't
yeah I can't differentiate a lot of them
so I really thought your hair was really
cool but it's white but it's pink yeah
what is it about horror movies that
turns you on in a good like that makes
you just I mean you love them and I love
them I have my reason for them I told me
you know there's a couple things part
isn't fit for me is nostalgic because my
mom also loves horror movies and so
she's she's the kind that'll just turn
them on on a Saturday afternoon just
because they're fun so that's kind of
what I grew up with like what did she
introduce you to uh Oh God so many
things I watched carry with her for the
first time they're all gonna laugh
mm-hmm okay i watch with her for the
first time a lot of hit the birds I
watched with her this is this is
something I experienced with my mother
she used to make me watch like motel
he'll make them die slowly yeah that's
why I'm I watched a lot of those
it's a lot of like the little ones on
Netflix that I I don't even know what
her old's game I haven't seen Jeff buddy
directed at Mike Flanagan he was a guest
listen listen to me if you love horror
yes go back and listen about three weeks
ago Mike Flanagan he directed dr. sleep
he directed the haunting of Hill House
and created it he's an amazing director
and you should work with him and I'll
put the good word in I love that and boy
I mean he it's a great interview I'm not
toot my own horn you were there I am I
was there yeah it was really good it was
good I was like a kid in a candy store I
was a little talking about the shining
like I mean everything Stephen King and
so for me when I watch a horror movie
it's like a roller coaster ride it's
it's adrenaline yeah I want to be scared
and my problem with movies nowaday I
know I sound like an old dude but I just
nothing scary nothing really scares me
yeah jump stuff I want something like
like I talk about this like insidious
was a great
that movie scared me so much oh my -
lips there are very few movies that
actually terrify me exactly I love the
suspense so that's what I love is that
it's that adrenaline of sitting there
and watching it and maybe it's the the
game of it all maybe it's the you know
I've also been toying with the idea of
directing but maybe about that I will
talk about that but it's the the toying
with that idea of the formulaic nature
of how do you do that how do you build
that suspense properly and then let it
deflate just enough so the audience feel
safe and then it really you can scare
it's genius yeah when it's done
correctly and unfortunately you know if
you think of movies like if you guys
like horror movies you that aren't gory
there's a movie called the orphanage no
Toro that will blow your mind okay we
want to see a zombie movie want to see a
good zombie movie train to Busan okay
you want to see a cool horror movie
that's really original with a great
score and shot well it follows I was
gonna mention it follows that's one of
my favorites we should watch horror
movies I have horror movie night i
screen horror movies with a bunch of my
Mormon friends I'm friends with my buddy
Jon Heder is Napoleon Dynamite yeah he's
Mormon amazing I love him and he's like
very family-oriented he kind of it's
just good he asked me over for dinner I
see what you know it's family but they
come over we watch horror movies we dig
up we just really search for good ones
it's hard yeah but anyway but that one I
love because I love it follows because
it's so simple
and it's that concept it's also one of
the the best abstinence movies ever
because it's like from hell yeah it's it
sort of is you're like what the hell so
if you have sex with if somebody has sex
then it goes to that person and that
person that the guy had sex with right
and then it's it's the thing that will
follow you at a steady pace a slow pace
but a steady pay forever forever until
it kills you and then it goes back to
the person who gave it to you unless you
pass it on to somebody else and you
never know when your times they should
make it follows - they said but this
time
they could bring but they why can't they
do have like gay characters because
maybe you know that there weren't any
gay they assume that sex is just a man
and a woman I in in this movie but what
if it's well I guess the characters just
happened to be straight right but I'm
not saying it's a bad thing I'm just
saying maybe in the sequel you know it
could be anybody
yeah well I'm saying you know I was
thinking what but sex someone that
person would get it but they didn't have
any but sex if you think about the story
logic that's actually a valid question
you could stuff about sex with anybody
yeah I mean I'm curious are you gonna
dig yourself out of it though well I
could just talk about you know is that
really not good what I just talked about
I think it's fine I mean it's yeah it's
not the most Orthodox question but it is
a valid question given the story or
discussing I was defending gay people
exactly I just want to see more days the
one horror movie I did see this year
that actually terrified me was us it
that's where we differ oh really I felt
it was here's my problem with us tell me
because the director the first one was
brilliant Oh get out get out is just
brilliant
yeah I'm not gonna sit here and kiss
someone's ass if I look great director I
looked great right off the bat you knew
none of this these family members were
gonna die there's no threat and it was
just like we're talking a lot of Tears
it just seemed like what are we doing I
was just like off the opening scene
was scary and then it just got it bored
me it became kind of funny and then it
wasn't funny and it was supposed to be
scared I wasn't scared you were scared I
think it terrified me in the way that
black mirror terrifies me and there's
just these these underlying concepts in
our humanity that you kind of wonder the
what-if of who we are as human beings
and that what what lies within us is
scarier than anything any monster that
could be lurking somewhere yeah
that's kind of what terrified and the
whole mirror thing also really freaked
me out
I remember I was I was actually staying
at the Sutton hotel at the time in
Vancouver where everybody who's anybody
and and every actor stays there every
actor says there hasn't been a redesign
since 71 it's true and you know how many
glass doors and mirrors at the shining
yes I get back to my hotel and I'm
sitting by myself in my room like 2:00
in the morning and I can't sleep because
there's so many mirrors and glass
reflective I'm just staring at my
reflection you were creeping hours and
hours on it I couldn't I couldn't move I
couldn't sleep I couldn't do anything it
really got to me Wow and the whole
spider thing yeah I don't even remember
it's the song that the little girl sings
oh yeah yeah and then I didn't realize
it till the end the movie but the lyrics
of the song are basically the plot of
here's what I was thinking when I saw
that poster yeah and as a publicity
thing they had the golden scissors or
whatever they were kind of you know
giving to random people I want to pay
this looks great
someone's gonna get like stabbed in the
eye someone's gonna get these scissors
have some like I just was expecting a
really scary movie yeah and to me I just
it just fell short that one but get out
was brilliant so I gave get out a solid
b-plus and I give us a c-minus I feel
like I need to get a list of horror
movies from you that aren't like the
standard I will give you a good lesson
I'm good like that
I am jaded I okay I'm jaded because I've
seen so many horror movies and so I
feel bad sometimes saying it but I'm
like I wanted to have like a horror
review at my own show mmm-hmm and I go
I'll never work again people will hate
me who wants to come on I don't know
they just don't make a lot of horror
movies anymore or they go right to the
shelf
and but you know what they do make a lot
of mm-hmm Christmas movies they do you
made a Christmas movie I did make it for
Netflix yeah what's it called it's
called spirit writing free spirit of
Christmas and it's for the family right
yeah it's a it's a lovely animated kids
film it's 45 minutes it's a sweet little
Christmas train ride it's it's a really
good thing and I sing what songs do you
sing I sing
new original Christmas songs they I
didn't write them but they're original
to the to the show are you that good of
a singer that you could just you could
pick it up it was easy for you I was
able to pick it up I'm so used to it
when I was in New York I would do
readings all the time of new shows and
things like that I'm used to getting
there's ones I got a nine song score or
I had nine songs in the musical and I
had to learn them in a day and a half
that's not gonna happen for me this is
why I question acting it's like that's
too hard how did you do it you just do
it you memorize the songs I didn't have
it was script in hand so you have to
know the melodies but I had to know it
enough to but could you hear it before
and then redo the verse like I feel like
mmm swimming in the snow can't you just
then look at it and go oh can you put
that back in yeah do you do that that's
kind of what I so they would I think
they either sent me tracks or I went
over it with them for a day and recorded
everything and then I just I literally
listen to it non-stop if it's something
I have to learn especially musically
quickly I'll turn it on repeat while I
sleep and just let it play over and over
now what's the song what's it what's a
song from there that you remember just
you're not gonna sing it
no no who's your favorite band like what
do you what do you like to listen to
well right now I've been playing in the
heights soundtrack from the Broadway
musical on repeat because I met Lynn
years and years ago and I was in New
York and he made a real impact on me and
him and his whole team seeing them have
such astronomical success it it's so
touching to me because they have the
genuine amazing hearts and the true
superhuman talent to match and it's so
rare that it that happens in the world
that amazing success happens to
incredible people who are so
phenomenally talented oh it's like the
trifecta of just rightness that never
happens and I had press all day
yesterday so I wasn't able to watch the
trailer until I was crawled into bed I
couldn't stop crying
I watched it within ten minutes I was
just bawling my eyes out because it's
just it's I know I know their hearts so
well and it's just a huge step for them
and it's just a culmination of
everything that they've worked so hard
for so many years and now I've just got
the got the Broadway musical I'd repeat
because I just it makes my heart happy
you know right I don't know about you
but when I'm listening to Kathryn I get
this sense of like like this is just the
beginning for you like like I think I
said it might be that maybe last thing
but I just you have the very few people
have this but you have that sort of
Kristen Bell feel to you oh wow you have
that like well you know it is people
like you because you're genuine you know
they say Oh Kristen Bell's America's
Sweetheart whatever and she's an awesome
person she came on the podcast opening
up about our depression she's like you
know I never talk about my depression
like this I go will you stop just no no
it feels comfortable yeah but she is an
amazing woman
charitable beyond I mean like
unbelievable I could learn so much and
have learned so much by her from her
when I see you I just see that same kind
of that pop that personality that just
like I want her in my movie I want her
and I know that
Shadowhunters was a hit I know that you
know you did the Christmas special
Netflix and they're all great and you're
doing arrow and that's one of the
biggest shows on TV but I seed like even
bigger and and I'm gonna say bigger you
don't need to get bigger to be happier I
just think things things these things
are gonna happen to you
it's just obvious thank you I appreciate
I mean the whole goal is to continue to
tell stories that move people and some
things that are interesting things that
reflect the human experience in a way
that makes people think and makes people
kind of question the way they do things
and and think about things in a way that
they might not otherwise have or just
reminds them to feel something because
in this world I don't know I feel like
in this day and age with technology and
with filters and with everything that we
have in social media where everybody's
you know presenting the best version of
their lives as we all do and that's kind
of what social media is but we forget to
be human sometimes we forget the
vulnerable ugly weird dark parts of who
we are and of what we go through what
are the ugly weird parts of you ugly
word parts of me I have a lot of them
like what okay I don't even
think of like when you think of like I
don't really love that about myself I
want to change it one thing I would
really like to change I'm very
directionally challenged an election
elite resurrection elite challenged and
it's it's kind of silly and it's getting
to a point where like I need to be a bit
more of an adult about this but look
where you're going
yeah like like in a car yeah this is a
flaw of yours how about this this is
just everyone I never know where I am
where am I now
bad look Michael when it's to the point
where you're your close friends you say
oh it's this way they go 180 degrees in
the opposite direction and they're
usually right that's a problem that's
not really a flaw here okay I'm not
taking I just want to know like you said
there was a couple of things is there
something like maybe like for instance
I'm just saying this because I think you
have a beautiful nose but I'm just
saying you ever look in the mirror and
go I hate my nose or do you ever go I
hate my lips I hate my eyes I think my
ears were weird in photos I like never
wanted my ears to show I don't know I
just thought they look funny
funny how I don't know it just I can't
quantify it and I could never come on
you just didn't love your ear just
wasn't great and then somebody pull me
aside one day and said no that's they
don't look funny they don't look weird
they're just yours and that's just you
and I went you know what you're right
that's silly have mated did someone ever
say anything to you some guy you're
dating or some somebody who was like hey
here's a little crooked no I think I
just saw one you know there's there's
always one photo that you look at and
you're like that looks odd okay
surely but you know what I mean it's
like you'll be looking through social
media and sure there's one comment mix
with yeah you know what I mean it's that
kind of thing and I think that's what
stuck in my head somebody you know I try
not to do anymore but somebody just said
something like there's somebody I look
like and I looked at them like I'm like
in my head like kind of like I never
played that game with people I don't
care anymore it's just like you know
I've heard a young Chevy Chase and I've
heard things
Chevy Chase you know so your ears you
thought for a while because you are you
get your ears are covered today with the
headphones in the pink hair no but it
was something that here's one I can
actually talk about hang on you can
actually talk about because it's a good
one it is a good one okay I'm a tiny
human you know this about me I'm tiny
I've always been small I had completely
written off having any kind of real
physical strength I thought it was
impossible for me cuz I'm small I
thought on I'm tiny I'm never gonna be
strong in any when you're smaller like
you're thinking oh I can never be strong
yeah then when I started training for
Shadowhunters I met these amazing
trainers that said no no no let us show
you you can do this you just have to do
it in the right way because growing up I
didn't know how to train properly I
didn't know what to do I didn't have
that kind of knowledge right and it
completely changed my life it changed my
world it changed how I feel about myself
it changed my confidence in just being a
human and being an adult and it changed
the way I live my life so that's that's
kind of why Fitness is such a big part
of who I am it's it's my meantime it's
the one thing every day that I do for me
and I take a couple hours and I you know
do something positive every day yeah not
every day but I always make the effort
every day because I know there's gonna
be at least one or two days a week where
I don't have time for it that you know
that speaks to people who are to me it
speaks of people that are too skinny too
short too heavy too whatever and
everybody always has the excuse this is
how I am right this is just I have
family members who are like you know
this is just the way it is and I'm like
if you don't take a step in the right
direction and try and and it's all about
routine isn't it it's all about when I
stopped working out like I might you
know I had a happen with my family
so I stopped working out for two weeks
boy do I feel it I just feel
like I'm falling apart you know what I
mean I know it's fear mental well-being
it's for all these things you don't have
to look like god what's in it guys name
from Lord of the Rings Viggo Mortensen
you don't have to look like him right
you don't have to have a body that's
chiseled you just have to you don't have
to feel good about you about you and
whatever that takes you feel good about
you so you may hate working out but you
know what you're gonna feel better once
you start doing it and you get more
stamina and you get more whatever even
if it's just taking a walk or sometimes
you know if I have to be you know this
we often have to be at work it you know
really super early hours of the morning
I'll go run for ten minutes it wakes me
up shakes the cobwebs out and then I
don't feel like a zombie going into work
and it gets you know I'm suddenly open
and awake and present because I've just
kind of jolted myself what is a key to I
mean do you feel like right when
you wake up do you like oh my god I just
felt cloudy do you have a certain diet
other foods you're adverse you know
adverse reactions or do you wake up and
go I know what it's gonna take to make
me feel good I need to go work out I
need to go for a run I need to take a
shower or if you don't do those things
do you feel incomplete a lot of times I
mean obviously given the way I live my
life there are times that I have to be
adaptable which is just those are the
choices I make right now
being here on the show you have to be
adaptable to my crazy my crazy questions
know I miss is very I actually was
really really thrilled that you asked me
back so thank you really yeah I like you
I think you're a good human being you're
genuine and that's that's why I asked
you back thank you I appreciate it
but for me I I do like my mornings and
people give me trouble for getting up so
early especially the schedule I keep I
usually get up between like 5:00 and
7:00 every morning what time do you go
to sleep between midnight and 2:00
sometimes you get four to five hours a
night yeah I think that might be like I
don't know if it's schizophrenia there
was something my therapist said that if
you're if you feel like you have tons of
energy you only get two or three hours
of sleep
it could be manic I don't think I don't
know I've always been that way how do
you look so so like refresh how old are
you I'm 24 that's why you know it's
funny I thought you were 29 or 30 no way
I think as you carry yourself a little
more maturely then yeah
I probably knew this and I just was
looking at it was like not because you
look old or not your ears are weird
nowadays because how you hold yourself
thank you that's that's what it is
thank you very much maybe you'll get
some more sleep as you get older maybe
that's that's why I do love
international travel or just any kind of
plane travel because I sleep I don't I
that that is when I sleep
so no 20 pills no no but never a
sleeping pill no never a xanax
no no anxiety never alcohol not on
planes but you you have a lot of
occasional glass of wine oh I love a
good Scott have you ever been drunk yes
okay so these are these not on planes
though I don't like drinking no no he
doesn't who does that I don't you know
I'm gonna big drinker but like I'm just
have you ever smoked grass in your life
I actually haven't and that's because I
promised a friend of mine that I would
smoke for the first time with him and
we've been on opposite ends of the world
for far too long
but you can't wait for that joy I'm just
gonna tell you this I'm not a pothead I
don't smoke much pot do you smoke Brian
no okay but if you do make sure you get
the one that's the mellow stuff okay
it's only because it's just if you just
by the way if you ever smoke pot I'm not
condoning on that single smoke pot but
just take one small hit and wait 25
minutes and just see how you feel you
don't need to smoke a whole joint you
know because you're gonna feel like
and make sure it's the mellow stuff okay
if you're gonna do that
see I'm so much.i my thing usually if
I'm gonna go out with friends and have a
drink I just love a good scotch I drink
like an old man scotch
yeah that looks good no that's great
what kind of scotch Lagavulin that's a
good one's a good one I usually go for
Laphroaig but that's me looks like
mm-hmm where's that from France
no Laphroaig German Scottish Irish guys
do you think that was the French word
for frost you said Laphroaig Hogg I
don't know for some reason it's not
French that's what I get I mean I don't
think so I don't think it's French where
have you been that you really demand
that I go have you been to st. Lucia
no the ban no it's in the bridge
Virgin Islands how far is it from LA uh
it is I'm trying to remember because I
flew from New York when I went there I
think it was about a six-hour flight
from New York so 16 yeah you probably
would fly through Miami
it's honestly it's Neverland
it's amazing Lucia yeah other things to
do
yes there's so many things to do there's
mountains to climb there's beaches to
sit on there's things to swim there's
crystal-clear waters
it's gorgeous expensive I know how much
that would be a trip we could get into
that but I want to do that I think I'm
gonna get what time of the year I went
in January like right after New Year's I
forgot it was winter after three days
because I was going straight from there
back to Toronto to shoot Shadowhunters
and I had forgotten it was winter and
about day three I remembered that I was
going to Toronto gonna be CH warm sunny
beautiful but it's the kind of place
that will rain for ten minutes and then
you have the most glorious rainbow for
the rest of the day and the sunsets are
just unreal or you look wonderful good I
think there there's got to be a nude
beach somewhere but actually there's
there's all these little coves and
things that are just untouched beaches
that you can take a water taxi to and
they'll just drop you off and you could
just have your own private beach for
however long you want and there's the
inland is beautiful enough you can just
explore it and enjoy it and the food's
amazing and the people are so wonderful
alright I'm going to st. Lucia honestly
was one of the most magical times we've
ever had and one of the times so my best
friend he tells me obviously that I
never slow down and I had never been on
a beach vacation in my life because my
family always went to the mountains yeah
so I said I'm gonna take you to st.
Lucia and we're gonna sit on the beach
and you're gonna do nothing for a week
and I said it's impossible can't be done
I won't do it I challenge you he did it
and he got me to sit on a beach for a
week and do nothing nothing I mean I
didn't do nothing but I did more nothing
that I've done in quite a while
Wow I'm gonna go to st. Lucia I really
am gonna go to sinlessly you think I'm
kidding but I'm gonna go to st. Lucia
he's gonna think I just need to have a
vacation you know I haven't had a
vacation in a while where I just like
you know just
joy things I'm gonna end with this okay
I was really hoping Stephen Amell he
said he was gonna come by he asked me
for the code to my door and it's just
gonna come in we can keep talking till
it shows up I'll I'll act surprised I've
acted surprised before when Stephen
shows up in front of me out of the blue
really yeah episode 8 of 4 of arrow 804
804 why they call it 804 cuz it's season
8 episode 4 oh yeah yeah I think it was
actually called something else
Infinite Earths yeah it's a phenomenon
it is people are really loving it this
is it though this is the last season
last season of arrow is over they still
do crossovers with other shows I believe
so and I hear you're doing maybe you're
doing an arrow sequel they call it
potential spin-off series so basically
it's I can't really say how much about
it at this point because I'm you know
I'm sorry but here's what I couldn't say
the crisis changes everything
irreversibly so and that is what we see
in this this next thing it's watch this
next chapter is what happens to Mia
which it's me assume it's you it's what
happens to you if this key so you're a
big part of this story this benefits
yeah you yeah you'd be the green arrow
maybe I mean you go shoot it for this
already yeah you have yeah you already
know what you're making but and yeah are
you excited about it if it happens it
would be really cool it's a great I mean
honestly Stephen has built up this
character so much and it's it is a
legacy and you really feel that in this
season of arrow it's every episode is
kind of honoring a different aspect of
what has made the last eight seasons so
iconic and you so you know I've got some
big boots to fill moving forward episode
your what episode is aired episode 808
is the one that's next and that's the
arrow part of crisis on Infinite Earths
and how many episodes are left before
Stephen dies or whatever happens to him
well arrow doesn't die love this new
arrows never cease
I mean spoiler alert if we die it
doesn't die it's all they don't
die I don't know I don't know I think
you know cuz because a Batman dies it's
like it doesn't matter like that movie
us you're talking about when those
people in the beginning die you know
they're not gonna die these are these
are legendary
this is Batman this is uh these are you
can't kill Oliver Twist Oliver Twist
you're really good at what's the word
zip lining your zip locking your mouth
can't say anything I'm not trying to get
anything from you
no but for him to die it's like do you
not think you're gonna see the green
arrow again it's like it just doesn't
come on you think people are crying out
there I mean if you're really hardcore
fans which you are out there and it's
great show and these guys are awesome
but if you're watching and then Stephen
dies as green arrow mm-hmm are you
really going knowing that he'll be back
that's my take on it maybe I'm wrong
maybe the DC Universe has really taken
different they're like hey when people
die their dad like that Marvel movie I
didn't see it but endgame uh-huh did a
lot of people die oh well the one before
it
DeeAnn I think they're gonna come back
sometime you it's like you know
what it is it's Jason and Michael Myers
that's true if they're always better
coming back it follow I know on what cuz
you can't kill him it's true this is
just my theory it's true that's well you
never know I mean it's the crisis isn't
over yet but it'll be interesting to see
things moving forward yeah I am really
excited though to see for people to see
the backdoor pilot and then also this
the series finale of arrow is really
special and it gives us much closure as
anyone can expect on the wall eight
years of a series I'm gonna watch that
one
like I said I don't you know it's not
like I know what the hell's going on
it's like you know for instance when I
left Smallville after
seven mm-hmm I came back for the series
finale that episode yes I miss sixty six
episodes oh my god I think I watched any
of those why would i watch any of the
episodes that I'm not in well I don't
know
I watched six seasons of arrow to study
for it no good on but that's because I I
knew I was cast right I didn't know I
was playing I would didn't know I was
named for the olicity baby I didn't know
that my character was gonna be Oliver
and Felicity's child I had no idea I was
auditioning for a rookie cop that was
just kind of adjacent to the story right
and then I got a call from the
showrunner saying hey we're so happy to
have you on the show congratulations by
the way you're all averred Felicity's
kid congratulations okay great I'm sorry
what what did I just sign up for this is
insane cuz I knew I'd seen obviously you
know the internet explodes with elicited
content and Stephen and Emily have built
up these characters so much and given
them such backstory and depth and nuance
that it's a lot of responsibility to
take on and I knew I had my work cut out
for me which is why I watched six
seasons at the time of show because I
wanted to pull as many know you're smart
that's what makes you performance so
much so dynamic and I but I'm asking you
this if you were on a show arrow years
before and you got killed off or you
left the show after season four would
you continue watching all the episodes
it depends no it doesn't I might if I
really really loved the show if I
enjoyed the show as a viewer as well
which I don't know maybe I'm just a nerd
for the thing no I understand I think
for the first couple seasons when I was
on a show I would watch it and then
after that I was like alright unless it
was something like wow LexA mas' looks
interesting I'm gonna watch that you
know was an episode where I was good and
was like this dream sequence and or if
it was an episode that really I mean
Christopher Reeve was on I was like you
don't want to watch that that's cool
there were certain episodes but I
ultimately it just it just didn't make
sense yeah for me to watch myself
anymore I was like okay after 60 60 70
episodes that I just didn't know it
makes perfect sense yeah yes that's all
I'm saying yeah I'm saying that this has
been really fun do you do you like
Catherine
I do it's been fun thank you yeah man
you're so happy
I'm stubbornly optimistic yeah but
that's the way to be you know I'm like
that in certain ways like when I went to
Germany with my band Rob kept saying Rob
and Tom they're like Lally especially
such an internal pessimist just like he
keeps supposed to rain the whole week
I'm like no it's not if you check the
weather what does it say 70% like it's
not gonna rain why are you looking at
that just getting a plane and
land if you need a rain jacket get a
rain jacket when you get there don't
start putting negative in your head
it ain't raining or just walking out
probably yeah it could be out for up to
two days man we'll be back in a couple
hours that's that's the way I think I
really know when it comes to like
that right now I'll be fine
see for me I always find silver lining
if it's gonna rain well that's fine I
love walking in the rain oh it's not
gonna rain light some candles have a
fire pit it's gonna be fun do you like
Christmas
I do love Christmas do you have a
Christmas tree I haven't put it up yet
but I have one I have light warming
ornaments I put up can you put this on
fire I would love to you know what's
funny though is I've moved so many times
and lost or thought I lost my Christmas
tree about four times so I have about
four Christmas are you seriously
obviously they are obviously and I don't
I don't know I think I opened up an old
storage unit that I had and realized
that I had two Christmas trees and then
I had one my storage unit my garage and
then one in my closet in my house and I
went oh well I'm just very festive I
guess yeah you are you know what I think
I'd like you to come back at least once
a year
okay so you've come back this will air
probably you know in January great
perfect so then you'll have to come and
do an episode for the following year
because I feel like you're just you're a
good spirit you're a good egg and no
matter how famous you get you'll still
come back always even if this is one of
the worst podcasts ever and not doing
well your parents are listening you'll
still come back oh for sure
I actually can't tell you the number of
people that come up to me and go oh my
god I listen to you on Rosenbaum's
podcast
really
and they know me from your podcast
before I've met them you know I get that
a lot where people will say I didn't
know much about Katherine McNamara I
didn't know who she was I wasn't gonna
listen and then I listened and I really
learned a lot about whatever mm-hmm and
that's the whole purpose if they know
that I'm gonna try and get things and
and and make people make these actors or
musicians or athletes talk like human
beings
be human beings talk about adversity or
what they love or their great before or
whatever if you can normalize like you
know mental health and all that I
think I think it just helps so I like
having someone who has the spirit that
you do and that's just as important as
those people who have faced a lot darker
because it's you're the light at
the end of the tunnel maybe well and
it's not that it's not that I haven't
faced dark because I've been
through a lot of that in my life and it
got that's why I'm such a let's get into
that maybe someday someday but I got to
a point in my life where I could have
gone down a really dark path or I could
have chosen to deal with what I was
going through in a positive way and it
was kind of a turning point where I said
okay well I can wallow in this and let
it consume me or I can go through it and
be a better person for it on the other
side and learn to turn it into a
positive situation and maybe out of
survival maybe out of the people that I
was surrounded with I ended up on the
positive route and to me there's so many
things in life that are in the end so
trivial or so small or just passing you
by and there's no need to make them a
huge problem or to be upset about them
or be you know brought down by them if
if you can laugh about it and if you can
find the silver lining and move on and
move through it yes there are things in
life that you have to go through and you
have to feel and you have to acknowledge
and work through and feel and feel and
that's important that's why I do what I
do is to try and highlight those parts
of life but you don't have to live in
that all the time
you don't have to let that become who
you are you can allow yourself to grow
from it and move on from it and use that
as a way to make yourself stronger and
make yourself just to uh appreciate the
good in life because you know that it's
not always that way
Kathryn thank you for being here thanks
for listening to a Katherine McNamara a
lot of fun she's uh she's pretty dynamic
a little shout out to all my patrons my
lovely patrons here they are Alison Mark
Jason B I knew a guy named Jason dicks
in school but Jason D is not Jason dicks
Lauren G Nansen Nansen Nancy D she's
gonna kill me for that barry al Barry I
want you yell at me on patreon just say
Rosenbaum it's not Barry L but that L
looks like an eye Barry L Li s Jason W
Bob b-ball tax my good little ball of
Tex and you kick Yukiko Nikko P Jill E
Angelina G Trisha Dion K Emma H Kevin R
Robert B Gerry W Sarah V Taylor B and
Emily good old Emily thank you for
supporting patron thanks for subscribing
to inside of you it's been a it's been a
real treat so far I've had three great
guests now on the podcast we had Morena
Baccarin we had Stephen Amell we had
McNamara I've got some other great
guests coming up and then the videos
boiler we have some great guests coming
up for the videos I mean I got I'm doing
five podcast coming up next week which
won't air for a little while but they're
all video so that's gonna be need some
big comedians we got some we got the guy
somebody from maybe an HBO hit series
coming on
I think it's on HBO it is right yeah we
got somebody who has a very famous
family who's also famous who I'm gonna
get dirty with well that doesn't sound
right
anyway thanks for the support
joined patreon if you want subscribe
tell your friends about the podcast
and thank you for all the on like the
messages oh that's what I wanted to read
I wanted to read a message Brian oh
right these are letters from fans and I
think look I get all these letters and
especially like after the Stephen Amell
episode came on and let's say Michael I
have been wanting to write to thank you
for this podcast for a few weeks now but
this morning on the way to work I was
listening to episode 97 with Stephen
Amell and something was said that hit me
like a ton of bricks you said to Stephen
that he was in mourning of his show that
was a part of his life it hit me hard
because I am retiring from the Army
after 22 years the tears started
immediately but soldiers aren't supposed
to cry well we know that's not true my
friend
the last few months have been hard I
haven't lacked energy motivation I never
thought of it in this way until you said
it I am in mourning of my military
career I don't know where I Ryan but I'm
a little motional right now yeah I'm
just looking at this going wow anyway I
have never felt more alive as I did when
I was in combat or jumping out of planes
and hanging out with my brothers doing
dangerous crazy or plain just dumb
now that is gone I'm crying again as I
write this thank you even-steven have
helped me name this thing that I'm going
through I am in mourning
naming it has opened up the gates and
tear ducts gotten the ball rolling to
acceptance and understanding thank you
Bob
hey if I if I may offer a suggestion I
know you have actors musicians athletes
on your podcast have you considered
having any soldiers airmen or Marines
many are also musicians actors and all
Warriors athletes very few have the
resources that you have been fortunate
to have yet still learned to deal with
and grow from them just a thought
Bob you know what he just opened my eyes
Bob I'd love to have someone who's been
through it you know protected us and in
the Armed Forces and somebody who's been
through some stuff and can give me some
perspective more perspective because we
can't imagine we could just sit there
and say oh he's so brave and thank you
but the crap you guys go through women
men is
just we don't know all we can do is
thank you and it's sort of like that
gray area where you're not sure I mean
you see movies and you see TV and you
know you hear about people losing their
lives it's tough so Bob thank you and I
will consider absolutely having soldiers
or airmen and Marines on see these
letters are they're great
should I read one more sure okay this
one is from Jose
good afternoon Michael and team team
would be Ryan maybe Bryce Mia
Jess Jess just wanted to give a quick
insight to listener to a listener me and
change slash expand rose and bombs idea
of who his listeners are okay here we go
and they should have read this one oh my
apologies but I have never watched an
episode of Smallville in my life and I'm
sure the show is great I just never had
the time to watch the school work
couldn't have picked Michael out of a
lineup before listening to the podcast
well you're you along with others I
first stumbled upon inside of you via
Tiger belly that's Bobby Lee show that
had been on four times and he's coming
back and quickly backtracked and
listened to all available episodes and
have been listening ever since I
listened because the shows and
interviews are real Michael has genuine
curiosity and asks real questions that
anyone and everyone would want to ask I
divorced from my wife about a year ago
and found it so helpful to listen and
know that other people have problems too
we all do by the way buddy we all do it
doesn't matter who you are you have
problems if you're celebrities you
create your own problems we all have
issues to deal with and that there's a
path to continue no matter what life
throws at you so I just want to thank
the team Ryan Jessica Brice Mia for
continuing to do the shows even if Rosie
isn't getting rich off of them and plan
on becoming a patreon slash patron to
show how much the podcast means to me
cheers to an awesome 20/20 I swear to
God I didn't read this what I do is I
Jose Vega wrote that I just I get a
bunch of emails that just four words to
me from the its hello at inside of you
podcast com
letters and also if you tweet something
I'm sure I'll get it but she forwards
them to me and I just I forward them and
paste them all on one page so I could
just scroll down and read random and I
and I actually choose just not to read
them until I'm reading them to you and I
think that was pretty awesome they both
were awesome these letters Thank You
Jose thank you everyone for reaching out
taking the time to write about how you
feel about the show and you know also
write a review but thank you guys and
continue continue the support try to
breathe every day just breathe in
breathe out try not to go through the
motions like we all do and just enjoy
the moment man enjoy the moment thank
you for allowing the inside of all of
you
[Music]